we lived all over the world for a number
of years so I ran it from everywhere
it's happened in New Zealand and it
happened in South Africa and Beirut and
Romania the technology really changed
the way you even approach covering it
there is a possibility for the world to
be you know linked to the community why
it to the world and really have a kind
of global village I use different tools
and online collaboration for different
things
you now have fully featured mobile
devices that are basically convenient
many computers that you can work on and
phone on an email on it
I have also live blog from boats from
airplanes literally I have twittered as
the plane is taking off even now I
haven't met at least half of the people
in person and yet have quite deep
relationships with them people we're in
an incredible vortex you know like a
changing swelling moment and have the
world
you